fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby let's go let's do it first
of all I got it here handsome thank you
buddy I appreciate that now I looked in
the mirror and I thought nope today I
went really oh dry face dry hair dry
everything but my psoriasis my kid last
night bossy was we were wrestling yeah
and he looks early he says Daddy have a
bunch of boo-boos all over your leg does
it hurt like no it's not good and here's
what's wrong I go eating too much candy
yeah because that scares the show and
having you guys and loving you so much
and worrying about the world yes yes
that's what's doing that would be it
yeah now the the carnivore diet is
helping yeah but I dude I have to be
strict strict strict because you don't
have the plane when they give you those
those like cookies the whatever they are
yeah I could have one of those yes I do
spot so I'm like oh yes so very true so
people didn't believe me I don't know if
you remember this but I put some half
and half in my [__] coffee you better
be on it and douche and then I ate
something else like I was with uh wasn't
yours night shades like nightshade
vegetables no mine was uh mine was
stress or not not because didn't food
help you though didn't you mine was mine
was just not living yeah my mine was
yeah all of it yes of course yes stress
it was all stress but but so you do an
Elimination Diet there's no doubt that
diet helps with yours no [__] that I
saw instant decline in spots when I went
carnivore and then I was like I could
have just a little they think it's a gut
issue but stress your God is affected by
yes God is affected by whatever of
course there's an in congruity in your
life I have a whole idea about that
there's a Miss that's okay we all have
it oh yeah and you know that your body's
just saying hey bro get let's get back
to it get your [__] on track right
that's all that's okay and and cut some
people out of your life whatever it is
you know it's all just tell the truth
tell the truth tell the truth tell the
truth that's it just tell that that's if
I can say anything to anybody's young
just [__] tell the truth and do
things for people because it's the right
thing to do that's it well I do things
for people in soft spots yes yeah well
your your spots are the truth is not
doing what I need to do to run a
business all of that of course there's
probably look it's [__] hard
it's all hard it's like it's like you're
gonna fail all the time you know it's
like and you make mistakes and then we
all we take shortcuts because we don't
want to deal with that over there we
don't want to hurt this person we don't
want to it's [__]
you know I know they need spots and you
can't have cookies anymore you're
literally like in my you're my following
my footsteps your teeth need now your
teeth slowly you got the old monster
rice it's all good here's any day though
here you're good good body good hair
good strength dude how about this
speaking of good body good strength so
David Lucas is usually my feature he was
headlined in San Jose hey told me like
can't do Springfield like I actually get
a local comic
so we get to Springfield I had no idea
what to expect in Springfield top five
clubs I've ever done Blue Room comedy
club in Springfield fantastic really the
owner Chris he's Hustler Chris I'm
coming it's so good the town's great
they have a great Hotel a great Hotel
good food good coffee great crowds sucks
to get there whatever then they have the
Bass Pro uh which is why I'm rocking
that they have the Bass Pro Shop the
giant aquarium shits on the Long Beach
Aquarium you don't need to bring it up
Jen please don't so it has a we already
done shop show but uh it has all that
like shit's on Long Beach Aquarium
shit's on SeaWorld some billionaire
build all these tanks so it's massive it
takes four hours
there's an aquarium hold on there's an
entire Zoo dude at the Bass Pro Shops
great restaurants coffee black rifles
there they're headquarters there they
have a headquarter like coffee shop
there nuts so me and Jay do all that
club's great I didn't bring a feature
and I was like I'll just book a local
guy they'll appreciate take the work me
and Jay are sitting there this guy comes
I'm not trying to make you laugh this
guy comes in his name's Willy he's on a
walker he's 90. he goes I'm uh I'm doing
uh five minutes I go oh okay we're okay
buddy okay and he stumbles out and then
uh the host comes in some young kid he's
like yeah so did you talk to will I'm
like
the guy with the Walker the 90 years
yeah I go no no he's not he's not open
up for me he goes no dude he's the he
opens up he opens up for Nick Swardson
when Nick was here yesterday that he's
our guy and I was like you're sh am I
are you guys [__] with me that 90
year old guy like yeah Whaley everyone
knows Willie like Willie's a local favor
I'm like no Willy's not opening up for
me he's 90. like okay but that's what
he's scheduled to do I'm like you're not
[__] like no like I guess Willy's
gonna do it he's 90. he's from New York
grew up with Sammy the bull knows all
about Samuel the more I talk to him like
oh he's on witness protection has to be
yeah has to be yeah he's nine he started
when he has to be 55. I was like what
brought together he's like you know
cheaper live and the the you know Bass
Pro Shop like oh this doesn't matter and
then his hearing aid he had a hearing
aid you'd have to say everything so loud
is he legit how old was he legit so what
do you gotta be nine he just heard his
90 today
his name's Willie what are you talking
about I swear to God his joke so he's
and he's he's dirty so this is one of
his jokes he goes he comes out this side
comes out of the crowd he gets up there
and was like what the [__] is the old
guy doing he gets out there right off
the bat he goes ah name's Willy he goes
you know why lesbians don't use these
two fingers to please each other and I
was like cow he's old school you know
how he goes because they're my [__]
fingers
laughs
[__] honestly okay already you're off
you can't help but no oh my God
these are my [__] figures
[__] you're like oh this guy's great oh
man he's great so he does the shows he's
so funny God bless Willie early show
Saturday he gets done and then I go uh
Hey Willie good set man I'll see you got
one more set and he goes no no no no I'm
tired
yeah I gotta go to bed
literally was like see you later
stumbled out then you're in Missouri
which is Kansas City chief land the
Super Bowl he comes in he has a he has a
Bengals jacking on like old school he's
not making a lot of money Bengals jacket
and the the owner goes Chris goes Willie
the [__] you you took the local bus here
in that [__] Bengals jacket is yeah
he goes it's the Bengals we're a cheese
Town somebody's gonna beat the [__] out
of US ah shut up you know they paid four
dollars for his thing goes I thought it
was a basketball team
I was like this guy's great he's gonna
die oh these guys
I gotta get there nobody just leave it I
go hey Willie so I'm telling you I'm
blue cover room every time I do tour
every year I'll be here man so see you
next cheers maybe yeah what do you mean
maybe come on I'm 90. I don't you're
gonna be here dude positive thinking
goes oh I'm positive he's in World War
one he's in Korean War has great stories
he wasn't in World War one but I'm sorry
uh I'm sorry he was in World War II and
then Korea yeah wow in the Air Force wow
but again he couldn't hear you have to
say everything twice until I start
talking about Sammy the bull it's not I
go the same block as him grow ran the
same groups as him no he's a good guy
how's he
they're like sharks you don't mess with
them they don't mess with you but if you
mess with them you better be ready to
pay the price I was like Willie I
thought you couldn't hear us though uh
was it you that I was with the guy who
does the merch for the Hell's Angels no
was not with you where I said what is it
like to hang out with him and he said
they're grizzly bears like as long as
you understand yeah yeah he's as long as
you realize you can hang with him nice
to you might even be getting invited to
the to the clubhouse you guys might hang
out you guys are laughing and everything
else but the minute you forget that
they're grizzly bears and you're not a
grizzly bear the minute you think you're
a grizzly bear you're gonna get [__]
checked yeah be careful yeah because
there's a guy from another chapter who
comes in and goes I don't know who the
[__] are and I don't give a [__] but
you're their friends but I'm gonna punch
you in the face because I don't like the
way you're behaving yeah yeah Willy
Willy couldn't hear until you brought up
the mafia thing it was pretty perky
pretty deep Jay looks Amigos he's in
witness protection right I'm like has to
be came out to Springfield
is great though dude great it's a great
Steakhouse there are a lot of hidden
gems oh it's good in this country there
are a lot of hidden gems and Nick
Swardson was there I post a picture of
him flipping was there because he was
doing somewhere and uh then they reached
out to him like Hey you want you want to
do uh look at him look at him
he's so great the Italian Lego and then
he wanted to uh come and go they just
yeah he's ridiculous
they just asked him if you want to stay
there and then uh he was like yeah I'll
perform tonight and just did a show will
he opened for him that 90 year old great
yeah was he doing a theater out there
what was he doing yeah I think so I
don't know he's doing out there but he
just stayed out there for like five days
he loved the city so much so he's just
living on this the hotel there's great
really great what's it called it starts
with a v i don't know Jay Buck did but
it's like an old hotel what is it new
hotel like it was like a pendry hotel
style really nice but not but not pendry
prices nice dude I gotta get myself into
that bathroom That Bass Pro Shop you'd
you'd go there every day you bring your
kids I mean it's Sea World dude
oh bro you got alligators you got sharks
you got large stingrays
you're talking about [__] that's just
there no no like straight up like The
Long Beach Aquarium it shits on that
like crazy stuff dude if you take your
time it takes four hours to get through
it it's so big massive in The Safaris
you can go on if a restaurant Hemingways
restaurants there now here's the big
question from Los Angeles how long does
it take you to get there a couple days
two days or three oh dude my flight was
delayed I touched down to the delays
they they already started the show I had
to rush there didn't get to go to the
hotel because it delays you have to go
from here to Dallas then Dallas has like
several flights into there but from here
to Dallas there's no Direct
Jay had a direct from Denver though um
but yeah it's not easy to get to yeah
boys I'm telling you it's worth it great
I'm 100 and the way they run it picked
me up from the airport that's what order
a steak drinks were great the service is
great the way the weight staff was great
the owners won the best he reminds me of
Keith from Wise Guys but younger he's my
age Hustler honestly it used to be a
church used to be a church and then for
a reason they stopped doing they're
doing the pandemic he's like he walked
he's like this is a comedy club [__]
comedy club and he's a comic so he knows
that like everything was great I love it
all right great I got it great area you
have his number call him yeah yeah we've
been texting he really I woke up to
Texas when he randomly texted me ninjas
hate crunchy leaves
all right dude all right that's true
yeah that's a funny joke okay ninjas
hate crunchy cheese because you gotta
sneak up on somebody did you get that
from Willie it's a great [__] joke
actually it's actually a Haiku poem it's
funny huh yeah maybe let's take a little
break take a little break buddy dude I'm
gonna I'm gonna come back in about two
weeks ago a lot Tanner because I'm in
Naples next week doing stand-up dude
Naples Florida caught me off the hook
February 16th 17th and 18th is Naples
Florida Bakersfield one night only
February 23rd that's almost sold out one
night not adding shows I can't so get
your tickets now then Brea's one night
March 3rd that's a Friday two shows
March fourth fourth is a companion for
the Big Jon Jones fight so to cancel
that Saturday but March 3rd two shows in
Brad California Bakersfield One Night
February 23rd then Naples is next week
that's Thursday Friday Saturday gonna
get a lot more tanby I will not be
getting 10 when I'm in Edmonton Canada
opposite of 10. comic strip I hear it's
a little cold there I'll be at the comic
strip in Edmonton February 20 3 February
24 February 25. Nashville Tennessee
Zanies March 2 3 and 4 New York New York
Sony home March 11th West Nyack New York
Levity Live March 16 17 18. yes buddy
well listen UFC 284 is this freaking
Saturday fighting but I like making
money well UFC 284 got you covered man
this Saturday we're doing fight band
with Joe Rogan tune in yeah makshev is
fine to keep his title against
volkanovsky they're here to make history
two division champs here join the MMA
action with draftking Sportsbook the
official Sports spending partner of the
UFC new customers can bet just five
bucks and get 200 in bonus bets
instantly now we talked about it B I'm
taking volcanovsky via decision that's
the dog that's the prop bet decision
though okay that is the that's a gutsy
decision I like Josh Emmett too so if
you want to Parlay freaking volkanovsky
and Josh Emmett the two dogs
and I got Market chefs so the
housemakers have it with you too I get
it dude if they decide isn't enough for
you cool Super Bowl Sunday is happening
this Sunday join the big game get on the
action with DraftKings what do you got
for that who do you got for that I like
the Chiefs okay I got the Eagles see
what happens okay
on that download the app right now use
code fighter new customers can bet five
dollars on UFC 284 and get 200 in bonus
bets instantly this Saturday at
draftking Sportsbook with the code
fighter minimum age eligibility
restriction Supply see show notes for
details DraftKings yeah do you watch uh
do you watch physical 100 have you seen
it no Jeff dye was kind of obsessed with
it yeah people love it right it's kind
of like uh squid game but but real life
Netflix it's it's the most physical
strongest people in Korea and they're
all rocked out of their minds they're
like jacked Asia right jack that jacked
like crossfitters and [__] like that and
then what do they that guy is huge yeah
they're all real athletes except for
that guy's a bodybuilder so the
bodybuilders don't fare too well when
they have to wrestle with the guy on the
Korean national Korean wrestling team
also heavyweight so what are some of the
events MMA fighters National wrestlers
uh Skeleton Crew uh uh um
they're [__] way they're huge Bubba
they're huge oh Koreans are look at [__]
and athletic and strong and there's a
traditional comedy's Japanese right
Japanese but you know sexyamas in this
yeah sexy amazing yeah yeah he's right
here and how's he do very well he had to
hang from you so so can I just tell you
it starts with this that you there's a
giant like sort of grid of bars
uh I'm very attracted to Korean women I
said that and it's that's a first I was
never I always thought they were
beautiful but this is a different thing
oh Japanese are gorgeous no it's Korean
never confused Japanese no idea that's
why I said old comedy yeah yeah of
course but um
but I will say this so the first
challenge is huge grid lowers okay
lowers and then you have to grab it
whoever hangs on it the longest so the
first 50 people time limit are you know
there's no time limit some people now if
you're smart you hang like the way he
was with your whole body over it yeah
but it still sucks yeah the Olympic gold
medalist who is a gymnast the gymnast
who won the gold medal he was the second
he blah blah blah blah blah blah
oh I shouldn't [__] I just spoiled it
yeah you spoiled all that [__] for
everybody all right I'm not gonna spoil
it can you bleep that part out yeah all
right bleep that art because I don't
wanna so so then they have then you'd
like this one they have you'd be like
you and me and there's a ball there's a
ball and a pool of water whoever's
holding the ball at the end of the three
minutes oh that's cool it's gonna his
wins and you just go as people go how do
they decide how to match them up well
you pick a sexy yama's going against
that chick you get to pick your your
person so the winners of the hanging
thing get to pick who they want to do it
with now I wouldn't pick you a guy like
you 100 wins because you're a wrestler
you're big so you could just you could
just keep somebody off and then last
second you could don't get it off right
then they have then they break them up
into teams they fight everybody votes on
the ten captains that they want and you
got 10 captains and they choose their
teams and what do they win
wow I'm not even sure yeah it's crazy
but but meanwhile this is the [__]
craziest one there's no black guy there
is a black guy there is a black guy
black Korean guy yep speaks fluent
Korean holy [__] and there's a there's a
there's an American six foot six
baseball player play for the
Diamondbacks now plays in Korea he's six
six I mean it's it's a really deep
feeling hey bring up the cast so I can
show you like what so the [__]
uh have to do this this was the weirdest
one
do it now now you're gonna ruining it
yeah I wonder if can I say what the game
is I want I wouldn't just save it the
game with the five is just ridiculous
don't show me anything uh because I
don't wanna this is the cast that's
chosen is basically
um yoshihiro akiyama sexyama he's Korean
and Japanese that's why and like
anything else you're always surprised at
who you're always surprised at who's
you want to see pictures all right
but you're always surprised
I never called that guy to win but you
know I bet like that bobsledder's
probably no punk right
because they have wrestling national
team swimmer yeah they're gonna be
monsters yo-yo is a model now team
wrestler crossfitter crossfitter yeah
wrestlers do very well
typically what is cerium wrestling what
is that
um
wrestling huh wrestling of eels that's
what I thought into their mouth right I
don't know I don't know I don't think so
this one eel sauce
casino dealer fitness model but she's
dimed up she is some of them are dimed
the [__] up
oh I can't tell which of the female
names what should be it's super tough
Kim it's all Kim swimmers
Tarzan Tarzan's good looking kid
YouTuber some of them are impossibly our
old case Special Forces and I TR yeah
now here's the other thing I'm going to
say out loud there's no doubt I want to
be respectful they're on sauce there's
no doubt that sauce is made its way to
Korea oh yeah I mean oh yeah
not everybody but you know
wrestling traditional sport Korea yeah
they grab like the big wrestlers it's
like Sumo but Freestyle Wrestling very
well represented in the Olympics I might
add the Koreans in in wrestling very
well represented Judo and Korea and uh
yeah they're not winning the rest of it
yeah I hear you uh took silver medal uh
when when kale Sanderson won the gold I
believe he wrestled are you talking
about early no but they still are
competitive they're still competitive
they're not a top Powerhouse not even
close I think they are bring it up chin
bring up medals in wrestling yes yeah
who who uh Korean America America who
meddled best in wrestling
very well I think uh uh do I don't know
what was the Olympics no uh
just put that metal uh gold medal top
countries that medaled in wrestling yeah
Olympics right yeah there it goes
Olympics
you could do all time
Soviet Union Japan's on there
turkey Iran yeah I don't know go down
did it keep going kid it'll be on there
no just that's fine
so Japan Russia United States Japan I
never would have thought that
huh
oh there's all the metals United States
Bulgaria yeah Bulgaria that's what I
said
Korea's not Powerhouse in Russia yeah
that's obvious
no they they they work they've done some
good stuff no it's not unusual to see
Koreans
they're not a top five on anything hold
on hold on guys well not top five we can
go top ten
I'll be sure I know ice skating they do
well
no they do a lot there it is don't sleep
on them she says don't sleep on careers
don't see my career [__] right
there it'd be tough
um
yeah that show looks dope did you are
you caught up on the The Last of Us
I'm not okay I got sidelined by a French
show on Amazon called The Bureau about
the CIA about their intelligence
community and it's as real as it gets
have you watched have you watched that
war movie on Netflix about World War one
I've not
I might oh All Quiet on the Western
Front well it's a phenomenal book it's
it's a famous book right yeah so which
I've I've read twice the movie's so good
it's it's a seminal book about the
experience of world war one but that's
how this is it shows you how bad it is
Warfare yeah what different time yes
different time yes we don't fight like
that anymore the only thing that shows
worse than World War one was World War
II
yeah but World War one was worse right
as far as the fighting goes because the
trench warfare in terms of in terms of
misery so so the difference when people
talk about it was World War One was
still a war thought by soldiers yeah it
was still a war fought by soldiers on a
battlefield right and it was also the
first time that technology
was was introduced that that literally
decimated so the chemical warfare well
chemical warfare gas poison gas
um and but mainly machine guns yes so we
didn't so they show that yeah they're
doing this thing the idea of Gallant
gallantly being uh like charging the
line with your plumed hat on a horse
that when they're getting mowed down
it's literally like like shooting
fighting people with guns with a bow and
arrow because you'd run by when your
sword and you're you know and we've been
the Germans were like that's adorable
so tanks are better back then the
British came up with it then we had new
kinds of bombs and artillery yeah so in
World War One there was a cannon I
believe the British came in with that
when if you were 300 feet away or 300
feet away you had to you had to cover
your eyes and you had to have something
in your ears or you would blow your ears
Jesus Christ it was that powerful nobody
had seen that before
it's so well done it's dark obviously
it's about war but it's like five young
boys they're all excited to fight in the
Army like yeah let's go right and then
they're like these friends and they
thought they were it was just gonna be
something cool and man it gets dark it
gets so dark because because they're in
that shows them in the trenches and
they're like what happened and then it
shows what happened I'm like Jesus but
let me let me let me just give you an
idea of what trench warfare was this is
great so again World War II became a war
that civilians paid a price for because
you had carpet bombing yeah and they
bombed cities everyone destroyed
everybody
but of course the Holocaust all that but
with World War one so you and I are in
we're in the trenches we dig the trench
now the guys over there are in their
trenches and there's an area called No
Man's Land what you don't know is that
you got generals who are saying hey
we're going to launch an attack on them
we know they're going to be shooting but
we'll get some people into the trenches
we'll probably lose 10 000 people today
correct today correct and you you were
told that you'd hear a whistle and you
would run now if you didn't what
happened was you would get shot
afterwards for cowardly if you didn't
run the shot yeah and there were famous
stories of people getting knocked out by
shrapnel and then they didn't charge and
they're like we still got to kill you
because you know and then you'd have uh
you'd have people who are so
shell-shocked that would be they'd be
doing this and they'd be like I you
you're a coward so they put them on a
thing but what would happen to these men
was that when you're in a trench okay a
couple things one it would start to rain
it gets wet yeah this movie's not here
the entire movie oh well now you're in a
trench now you don't have anywhere to go
to the bathroom you see because you
can't go over so you have to shut the
bathroom there also when your friends
get shot they are dead there correct so
now they're covered in mud so now you're
in a soup of your own urine pieces and
bodies that's great that didn't cause
any disease at all no and you're not
sleeping now add to the fact that the
British and the Germans were digging
tunnels and they would tunnel in and
they put they'd get under you they put a
bunch of explosives under you and blow
the below you there's that too and then
if they got close to enough to the
trenches then they had guys with
flamethrowers who'd go through them
light it on fire please let's not forget
the chemical the mustard gas that they
would float across so you have to keep a
little Canary correct and if the canary
died then you were like get your mask
good stuff
um now here's the problem Brandon Hitler
got hit with mustard Geth Hitler sure
did he got blind find it now here's the
problem with mustard gas sometimes the
wind would shift and blow it back at you
or or this is a great time that's a good
time the mustard gas for whatever we
would settle and get into the water now
it's in the water now it stops raining
and can't get any water to the front
lines you could also smell the front
lines you could smell it from five miles
away let me say it again you could smell
the front lines from five miles away oh
it's good now you can't drink that water
but some people would try and then they
drink mustard how thirsty they were body
wash yeah yeah now I'm not done as you
were leaving when you were leaving the
trenches you see the problem was that
those trenches got super deep and super
muddy you ever heard a quicksand you
sure have now here's the great news as
you're leaving Brandon sometimes you're
all weighed down by gear and there were
a lot of stories of men who would fall
into to the muck and just disappear into
uh well you would die from from mud
you'd die from mud face yeah and there
were classic stories of guys saying
shoot me shoot me as they were going now
they didn't want to die that way Jesus
Christ yeah so when you say does Hell
exist on Earth the worst war of all time
yeah the Germans started it and after
they lost they weren't allowed to put
crosses over the Allies we're like
you're not allowed to put crosses after
this
is the [__] we've seen they literally
you want a crops all of you oh dude it
was so the movie portrays all this it's
so heavy yeah like when they sign up for
it you know because when soldiers get
shot like through the chest or in the
back they would take the uniforms off
send it somewhere wash it to be blood
everywhere then just throw a patch over
it then give it to the new guy you got a
good bike why is there a patch on like
oh it tore you're fine keep going yeah
and so many people died did I mention
they didn't have antibiotics really it
wasn't like a lot of them died from
sickness tons of deaths from
tuberculosis
yeah well you had the Spanish Flu
remember yeah that came after the war
Fields so after the work God was like or
the devil was like Hey listen guys
Europe I know we turned Europe into a
slaughterhouse turn it into a
slaughterhouse a little Spanish floor
yes Nisha predicted now let's let's drop
a flu on y'all that'll kill 50 million
people and you thought covet was bad
and Brennan need I remind you the
Spanish Flu wasn't into old people it
was into the young it was in the air but
yeah yeah and when you were flowering
when you were a young man you would die
yeah horrible time so the point is
movie's good but it's dark as you would
think it's not like did you watch did
you watch the that I sent you the most
dangerous comedy in the world yes yeah
yeah and just the first episode yeah
first episode yeah the other ones get a
little yeah get a little dicey yeah but
uh it's kind of cool are you gonna well
I was about to say are you gonna watch
UFC 284 this weekend but we're doing a
fight band Joe Rogan on Saturday we're
doing a fight companion with the great
Joe Rogan on Saturday each side for the
fights I am excited for the fights give
me a breakdown of uh Islam marketev why
don't we bring all this up Alex
smokinowsky your Coleman event is Josh
Emmett and yay Rodriguez yeah so I've
got I got a lot to say about this now
you know you know how they've been say
it's been under promoted it's on track
supposedly what I last read from a site
on uh Twitter it's tracking me the
biggest pay-per-view ever at beating
Connor that's why is that I don't know
who knows who knows very strange maybe
that's information from UFC trying to
you know not look bad I don't know okay
I'll be surprised if it was well I would
too
very surprised I'd be very serious now
because Islam has complained about the
promotion of this he's like you're gonna
promote the slap Fight League over this
fight yeah I can't remember last time
it's unheard of the number one power
pound which number two pound per pound
both in their Prime fighting this has
never happened as far as ever as far as
skill wise goes it's the highest level
fight the UFC has to offer in the
history of the sport I would agree with
you uh in some ways and disagree with
you in others name a bigger one well
Alexander volkanovski can [__] strike
and he puts his hands on your face and I
you know he's just one of those he's
good at everything and he's good at
everything but not so good he's not
known to be a wrestler slash Jujitsu
Master you know you you had uh t-city
almost almost uh submit him twice
keyword There is almost almost TC lost
that fight yes he did badly
um so so we know we're taking Islam
right we know that right I'm not
hold on sorry hold on let me just ask
this again sometimes we get it yeah
please you know what happens because
sometimes
you're a little hungry
I'm taking the dog so let's start again
go ahead let's start again go ahead so
you know that you know that Islam is
going to win that no disrespect to the
great Alexander volcanovsky no
disrespect we know that we know that our
boy Islam mochachev is gonna who should
be a 70 pounder he's gonna beat
Alexander poconowsky yeah we know that
right no no and I'm down to bet on it
again really I'm taking Alex be a
decision
well we we bet five grand last time now
I don't want to take your money I don't
want to be I don't want to be I keep
taking the dogs and losing yeah it's
easy to take the faves I'm gonna let you
set the price and I'll put my hand in
your hand at anything you you say uh how
about now be careful now be nice to
yourself so so if Alexander wins all
Alexander has to do is win and I get two
grand if my chef because he's the
favorite three to one favorite if my
chef wins he has to win by uh finish
there you go and so if Mike Chef wins
you get a thousand it's it's good yeah
because I'm still bet better odd still
two to one deal yeah two grand if Alex
wins yeah and then you you only win if
Islam gets a finish I like that yeah
because if Islam wins it's a nearby
finish I don't think what's that if
Islam wins this fight it's gonna be by
finish in the scrambles if he gets
Alexander volganoff's neck it's gonna be
a problem I think he Islam's gonna be
surprised I don't like the way it's
camped it's kind of I don't think
they're taking it too serious because
he's smaller he's small he's still fight
at 55 he's walk around 210. he's not
that small he's not that much he's a two
inch reach advantage and I think yeah I
think his height is going to be an
advantage because it's hard to get under
now he's gonna get taken down guarantee
he's taken down I think he gives me
tough to hold him down there I think he
gets back up and he wins against most
guys but the problem is Savage guys I
know
they just and the odds are on your side
B I just think volcanovsky with his
speed I think his speed's gonna be a
problem for Mike Jeff and they give away
his game plan already could be where he
gave it away they're so confident yeah
he's you're gonna Force the clinch beam
up the clinch wear him out and take him
down submit him yeah good luck that's
fine now now I will say this if you
stand and bang with a volcanovsky I
don't care who you are if he starts
connecting on your face he's not a
knockout or so I don't think he's Gonna
Knock much about he could wobble and
finish him off but he's not he's not
like a KO guy but I think between his
kicks you know South Paul versus
traditional I think his inside leg case
can be a problem
again I think his speed and quickness
and avoid being controlled on the ground
he's gonna win rounds it's gonna be
controversial because people are like
but Mike should have landed whatever
eight takedowns but that's not the story
of the fight yeah I don't think here's
the problem
um if it's strictly stand up I'm gonna
entertain this fight and I'm going to
entertain your argument I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get very excited because
strictly stand up Alexander volcanowski
will keep anybody busy and cause a lot
of days on your front leg he's too quick
yes all good he's gonna take it now the
problem is that that once he's taken
down he ain't getting back up well
that's the fight that's the problem
that's the fight if if because he's
going to take notes if volunteer gets
taken out when he does can he hang hand
fight get to his feet right away and not
get control the answer is no sir and
history is probably on your side on that
I think broken house is very hard to
handle and also I do think vogelsby one
of the first guys that actually truly
100 every fiber in his body believes he
can beat monkey I love that which is
huge in talking about between them they
have over 50 wins two losses yeah pound
for pound number 100 pounds per pound
number two until that guy grips you and
you're on the ground but because now and
he the the other thing I always look at
is volcanovsky my guess is doesn't have
anybody in his cabin that's a great camp
that is that is the wrestler that that
islamists
in guys now he needs I'm sure he's been
working on khabib said this I agree with
him he goes we've been doing it since
we're a kid so if vocal option wants to
focus on getting up good luck it's all
we do he's right but I do think they're
sleeping on uh volkanovsky I think
they're gonna have a harder time keeping
them down early on the reason he's a
champion champion he finds a way to live
so funny to win yeah he's never lost
he's so [__] good yeah and lost in
the fcially you know what I'm really
excited about you know what I'm more
excited about no but don't say the
co-made event no no no I'm actually what
I'm really excited about and I believe
this is going to happen mark my words I
believe Volcan Oscar goes back to 55 45.
Rodriguez
fights vulcanovsky and I believe that's
his toughest fight I believe that's
Vulcan obviously sophist fight yario
Rodriguez that's going to be tough for
him
huh yeah you don't think so what do you
think
no I actually think Emmett beats him but
really yeah really he's a dog too yeah
that beats him it's too tough just just
uh just match up why is the Irish flash
he's been on the streak lately but I
think he gets dealt with
um I I think vocalowsky there's so many
great fights I'm you know 45 is good
about at 55. there's a lot of fun fights
for him oh yeah I think we're gonna get
machev vocadosi a few times well this
won't be the last one I think we're
gonna get I think that let me see mock
Jeff is going to end up going up to 50
uh yes and he's going to be just as much
a nightmare for everyone at 70. you
would agree 100 he's been a problem yeah
now now now
if if our boy um
ayev can get down to 70. it'd be tough
that's going to be that would be an
interesting match I don't know if he's
hearing I don't know if he's hearing
that much from machachev's wrestling
he's he's familiar with that language
he's very familiar it'll be a great
fight be a great fight but I I think uh
that'd be a really calms out 70 of those
days are probably gone you think so he's
got to go he's got to go to 85 yeah
that just I know he has to just it's too
big yeah he missed weight loss UFC's
probably like get the [__] out of it but
if you can do it I'm excited at 70's
kind of a [__] show right now like they
gotta figure some stuff out yeah now
there's a 55er who's like I don't know
his brother I don't know who it is in
Bellator
who they were talking about flirting
with coming over I don't know isn't
there a guy who's devastating at 55 in
Bellator
I don't know his last name ends with a v
I'll look it up um
random they're in the same camp
um that's machev yeah I mean khabib's
though the cousins over there he's about
he's 35 though I think right yeah yeah
yeah
you said 55 right yeah let's see
who'sman yeah usman's a monster
Islam there he is yeah it was Usman yeah
he's a [__] 22-2 yeah don't be
surprised if Usman goes you know what
I'm gonna make the jump over to 55. you
go up to 70. let's just all us
dagestanis rule the roost and and by the
way while we're at it let's get the 35er
who's over there you know in there too
that that might be a
are you [__] General man you don't
know you wasted I know I know let's know
who's what do you data white promoting
UFC 284 and then
you you're the other guy you know the
Russian guy he's on defeat he can't mess
with him get him over there and then
with the switch and then you'll do the
run the gamut they say
how about our boy Juana [__] killer
out of Duke
um I worked with him on uh Kingdom yeah
he's a great guy yeah he didn't fight
this weekend I hear you dude yeah anyway
anyway
who's the last person Josh Emmett fought
who you think you're taking Emmett on
that yeah I'm gonna take your error on
that complicated oh boy that's no joke
your chance to start in your lifetime
you're gonna get in a car accident oh
man I've been there 600 car accidents an
hour five million car crashes in 2020.
okay 15 000 a day 600 an hour like you
said that's enough get injured your car
is messed up whatever it might be guess
what but there's a replication is it
millions of dollars to get a lawyer no
look you're first of all when you sue
you're not suing the person you're suing
their insurance company and that's just
to make you whole now you might think
filing a claim is hard you got to go
find a lawyer no not with Morgan and
Morgan Morgan and Morgan you can
actually do it from your phone it's
about as easy as putting in an Uber
order or something oh it's super easy
yes if you're ever in injured you can
check out Morgan and Morgan the official
Law Firm partner of the UFC Morgan and
Morgan is America's largest injury Law
Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers wow
listen it's it's it's so easy and eight
steps pretty much from your couch and
you filed your claim and their fee is
free unless they win so for more
information uh go to
forthepeople.com Fighter for the
people.com fire or dial pound law that's
pound 529 from your cell phone okay and
it's pretty much that simple you can
submit a claim without ever having to
leave the couch just open up your phone
and in eight clicks or less you're
already done that's for the people.com
finder or pound law pound 529 from your
cell forthepeople.com fighter
but yeah they're good fights though yes
the command would be fun huh
I can't wait I'm gonna do one in a hot
second I can't wait
be great I've been talking to Rogan a
lot lately
just shooting the [__] you liked his uh
pod with uh Jordan Peterson I find
myself agreeing with every single thing
that they say I had a really interesting
things I was thinking about with Joe and
I was like you know
we're different people but when it comes
down to like what we consider important
like our value system and our sort of
notion as a friend prioritize what not
to prioritize what's important what's
not what has meaning what doesn't I I
feel like I'm absolutely lockstep
lockstep so here's a friend though yeah
but
but I don't know
um if we arrived at that we kind of
arrived at that maybe we're the same
generation maybe we're the same
everything
yeah I don't know but how do you feel
like you're that way
uh with me and with Joe uh Jordan
Peterson as far as yeah I like when when
you hear I like to like like Jordan
Peterson right like he gets a ton of
hate right ton of hate and he goes you
know what's interesting Joe is I've
never gotten the streets he's like
social media's not real he's like maybe
in my entire life I've had six
altercations he's just awful when they
have but I've never have it I was
thinking about I was walking through the
airport you know people yeah I love you
man you also sold out people don't
realize that like you go to something
like the blue room and that many people
come and they love seeing you but that's
what I heard but that's that's what's uh
like that's reality like he always told
people like social media like how much
hate does Machine Gun Kelly get he's at
the Grammys last night I don't know if
he won but the guy gets millions and
millions of views tried to fight Sam
tripley
recently yes sir he went to back to the
Green Room at the comedy store and got
in Sam's face why because Sam was making
fun of white guys who act black
and he got bunched up about it on stage
recently yeah now
what did Sam do Sam is the monk Sam's
Sam's 50. what's he gonna do yeah now
I'm not a monk
so
what do you think I would do in that
situation be honest you try and settle
down like what are you doing you
wouldn't have attacked no she got you
tried no but do you ask you come back I
wouldn't uh come back to your green room
now I'm gonna be I'm a Machine Gun Kelly
fan I've been like hold up I'm like hold
on well I'm jealous I always said MGK I
don't know his real name or Colton or
some [__] like that what are you doing
yeah it's a 50 comic you came here
that's comedy what are you doing right
now yeah you're you're engaged in Megan
Fox you're upset about this
what are you doing yeah I would have
stood for that yeah I I think what I
would have done is I would have done
that too now if he got in my face you
have problems it's it's uh it would be
very hard for me to not be hilarious
forget your ass escalate that be
hilarious
it would be very hilarious it'd be
hilarious yeah be hilarious it'd be
hilarious yeah but he's a tall drink of
water yeah he's about this big yeah yeah
that's that's like I said it'd be very
hilarious you better you better know
what he's doing yeah
but it's very strange you go back to
talk [__] so you came from a
conversation you got offended and then
you want to talk [__] the comic and all
your talking [__] to comment [__] to
Comic who's beloved by all of us and
defends people a great guy yes all of us
yes like a real comedy if you have an
issue with Sam you have an issue with me
correct and I'm not saying no machine
gun silly I'm a fan of your songs but
I'm a light kick your stupid skeleton
jacket right on you can't hit him you
could never do anything maybe you could
grab and squeeze him up a little bit
right yeah yeah I'd do that yeah I
wouldn't hit him with the fancy get sued
even if he hits you you have to just
kind of go I mean you have to go if you
hit me game on but yeah but you gotta
and then go and grab them and just pull
them in you got to pull them in because
you're good at this you grab here the
Gable grip from here in the hips you
pull them right close your nose though
wow these are crazy well you squeeze
them you I've been squeezed by you what
you do is you squeeze that guy until
some ribs pop or he's or he pulls his
pants now listen pumpkin jack you keep
saying it from Cleveland you're from
Denver right you got to get people you
grew up in your arm Dragon get behind
whisper you're from Denver let's quit
the whole act right you're not from
Cleveland so come here you know it's
gonna hurt a little bit you're talking
[__] to Sam so I'm making sure your
pants in front of your girl say hey
Megan how you doing look
I just hold me is he still with Megan oh
yeah they're engaged I thought they uh
broke up no she was there with them last
night at the Grand guys she's good
people but but um you just kind of I
can't so what's Sam do
Sam he came back a second time he came
back twice and so what do you say the
second time he got he got on his face
again you know because because Sam came
back and goes Machine Gun Kelly just
tried to fight me on Backstage and then
he came back
and one other Comics around the show was
that either well I have a friend who's a
comic who said what's he doing keep him
there and drove to The Comedy Store it
would have been bad for Machine Gun
Kelly but you know if Sam could have
called me out okay I'm a fan dude I just
love your music what are you doing what
are you doing well if anything you're
not gonna say Logan had been there
you're not gonna sing the same I'm
telling if you keep this up yeah you're
gonna change
if any of us had been there like really
like the real guys well the guys who you
know yeah yeah it would have been you
guys will sell tickets I'm sorry what'd
you say it would have been something
different but but uh Sam's a monk Sam's
like Zen yeah he's a great dude he's not
gonna well that's insane I didn't know
that it's kind of it's kind of surreal
when when someone like that is in your
face and you're like young man
excuse me young man I'm a comic this is
you know what it is Machine Gun you're
very inappropriate right now you're
being inappropriate you're out of line
you're sir you're out of line if you
don't get back in the studio with that
pink guitar and play some [__] Tunes
I'm gonna twist your dick up he's very
talented I don't know his music yeah
he's talented yeah he gets a lot of hate
but he's super tired right yeah he's
doing something right he's very he's
very unique he's he dresses and I'm just
see the problem with me is I'm jealous
of him I'm a little jealous of his
Styles he's cool he's young you're
Rockstar there's a lot of stuff he's a
rock stars from he was like had your
hair has full-blown locks so I'm already
that that but I'm already a little
jealous so you can't come back to my you
can't come into my house and be that way
I've heard mixed things on I don't judge
anybody till I meet him personally I've
heard I've been kid I've had one good
looking I know Jesus Christ I know one
group that worked with him yeah like
complete nightmare tried to fight the
sound guy another group that was like
he's the best so yeah he's probably
great he's probably great he's
complicated dude he's a complicated guy
I mean he's [__] he that takes a lot
of time to he's got style I don't I you
know I'm not a style he has a style he
has a style she has all the stuff she's
a man she's a great person all across
the board fantastic human being but um
Peace I'm a fan but he uh I mean he's he
dates the most beautiful women in the
world look at him though he is a he is
more colorful than any fish you have in
your [__] tank yeah it looks like a
flowerhorn
anything you have
what's his background white yeah he's
[__] does he train at all does he
know hey no absolutely not no does he
train or does a lot of drugs and plays
music yeah that's that's the Cockiness
somebody's never been actually [__]
checked that holds the picture there
you just haven't been checked but it's
all good because I you got to have
people like that but not not if you're
gonna get actually you know what it is
you know what I resent
here's the problem you're awesome be
awesome you're stepping out of your lane
now though if you're gonna get physical
now you're stepping a little out of your
lane yeah yeah you don't know who you're
you don't know who you're coming back
yeah he almost got beat up by the
Slipknot guys because I I think Insane
Clown Posse because he's talking about
them and their fans are like excuse me
yeah and that lead singer just started
talking [__] about him so you gotta be
careful there's no reason for that
especially I like out of all you guys
[__] with Sammy the one or he doesn't
have to be careful because he knows that
at the end of the day nobody's gonna
punch him and he's gonna be fine no they
are though no they see that but see
that's my problem with Society but no we
are if I see you you get in Sam's face
dude if you [__] with Sam you're [__]
with all of us yeah that's for sure
they've been yeah
yeah out of all the columns can't get
Sam Smith he's uh he's uh Sam does too
much for comedy for you disrespect him
no that's it now if I'd been there it
would I'm telling you I would have [__]
on yeah literally took a [__] you're
getting now you're thinking about it
oh I'm mad I just find out about it it's
now getting I'd say oh MGK you're from
Cleveland ever heard of a Cleveland
steamer
are you familiar with a Cleveland
steamer yeah do you want that to happen
to you in front of everybody I'm gonna
drag you out on the main stage and [__]
on your chest leave Sam alone I have to
be like that's hepatitis and that's
probably gonna be that's gonna be
there's got to be an assault right if
you [__] if you put if you take things
out I'm not touching them all right well
you have to touch them a little bit no
am I holding them down yes so I've got
to get three times so he doesn't bite me
I'm get I'm lying down on the ground
here that's the Press we need I got him
here why are the kids
body lock neck lock slowly no big deal
no hey I'm friends with his lady so I
gotta I love her so I gotta be well get
your man I gotta be here otherwise
everybody can [__] and then I'm gonna
hold them here and then and then you're
gonna you're gonna poo don't miss dude
here's the thing so yeah it could get
messy it gets so messy this carnivores
come out hot oh God now that's no I
can't I can't have the meats on me you
have to no no I can't do it no upside
for it you know what I do we go machine
gun
Kelly you have to calm down
you're great you're awesome you're a
great young man you're great you're a
little bit you're the best you're out of
your lane and this is a little dangerous
you play the drums right he's a good
drum player you're getting into deep
water
you're playing drums right you're
getting into deep play the drums don't
treat your head like a [__] bass all
right yeah yeah see it's getting you
it's so just now you're gonna now you're
gonna be stewing and I'm a fan now you
[__] sakes yeah came back twice
and no Comics did anything
no one did anything look at me that's
the problem what do you think
that's the problem
how do you let someone disrespect that
ain't happening it was like it was like
the guy who uh I'm at The Comedy Store
and I'm sitting on the wall and a guy
starts he he started heckling Chris
Dalia and he was [__] with him and
then he started [__] with other
Comics started coming up to him going
like he was kind of a jack guy
but he was doing this too and then
finally he did that to Chris he went
like that or something like that
Crystal's never gonna fight ever in a
million years he was like oh Jesus
and you know me I see red and I was on
the wall I was with I think a bunch of
people were there everybody Chris saw it
Chris was right there and I said if he
does anything to Chris right now I'm
gonna [__] I'm gonna kill that guy
I'm gonna fight that guy right now
and he went like that to Chris and I got
off the I got off the wall and I saw red
you know I have my temper and I just
went okay now we're going
and I started to do I started to go I
started saying see now the difference
between me and those other guys is that
I'm gonna [__] kill you right here
and nobody can save you what'd he do and
I thought the bouncer was his friend
this is how crazy I was and it turned
out to be just a giant guy who was who
was actually working at the at the store
but I was so I was my brain was turned
yeah so I go and your friend I'll cut
through him like a knife to a hospital
like that yeah and I'm sure he's still
there but I don't remember you know when
I'm doing that I'm I'm gone yeah and I
started doing this I started going
because I started going see I can turn I
turn and I'm doing this stuff and he's
like you UFC and I go no I'm [__] you
that's how I know you can't fight that's
how I know you can't fight you UFC what
the [__] that even mean and I knew and I
was like anyway he he got he got very
afraid and he ran away and no one
confronts him right that's that's the
internet but I was like I'm the only one
here I'm a comic but I'm the only person
here at least speaks a little of that
language yeah and and everybody else is
being bullied I go that's [__] nuts
that's not cool
nuts yeah Chris isn't isn't gonna fight
I remember Chris was like uh
Chris did Chris was like hi something
like you get crazy yeah
you've been there's another story that I
I was with uh my ex wife with Amanda
back in the day and uh
I think you you weren't there this is
before it might have been before you
were doing stand-up or maybe certainly
before maybe we had just met each other
and Dove was there
and a guy starts mouthing off
to Dove or there's a thing in the street
no it was at the comic store I believe
there's a fight about to happen and the
guys I don't know if he was saying some
[__] to Dove or saying something to the
comic I knew and I didn't say anything
but I just got up and got behind the guy
because I was going to I was going to
punch him super hard in the back of the
head or choke him oh you could use that
out of line yeah I knew he was going to
try to do something to a comic and uh
and then it got but I was just standing
there waiting and I was like and I was I
remember going am I going to punch this
guy in the back of the head as hard as I
can but that hurt your hand yeah or I'm
gonna jump on him and try to choke him
yeah so um so I'm but I'm but I'm kind
of positioning myself and Hammer he gets
broken up and my my ex goes like this
she goes what were you doing like you
were standing weird behind him and you
were so close I was like ready to go I
was like I was going to punch him as
hard as I could in the back of the head
before he hurt my friend yeah she was
like how do you think that way I go how
do you not think that way how does
nobody else but where you're from but La
is not like that it's the only place
I've ever seen that's far like this yeah
that's why those people can get away
with doing that right because no one
calls them out I'm like this is a bad
situation yeah I always think worse or
the worst of course yeah well that's
because you've been in it oh yeah you've
seen it it's not good yeah for you I
think the only never punch the move is
you have to just hold them uh yeah
because you can sneak it because like
you know
Alex Baldwin on a show no yeah it's
funny
was it good yeah it's good what happens
with Alec Baldwin what is that I don't
know
he's been brought about manslaughter
charts they're like he still finishes
he's officially charged with uh I don't
know I don't think that's right
personally
well so apparently since he's like a
veteran of the movie game he should have
known how that stuff works the artillery
stuff you know the outside someone very
famous who's in Hollywood and he was
like oh that dude should be put in
prison like what do you mean he's like
well he's the director
the producer he's in charge of that he's
like you never he's like I don't do my
scenes with a gun I fake it he's like
why he wouldn't check the gun fire like
he's liable for it yeah you're not
supposed to fire it either I I I would
agree with that but there's another
thing about it because I've shot plenty
of guns on set whether it was ride along
or whatever and you know you have a lot
of professionals there when you're on a
movie Set It is the exact it is the
it's the director the the um
[__] ad it's the assistant director
and it is the armors and props job to
show you the gun so I've never been on
on a set with a gun where they did not
first show you the gun they show you
that it's actually how it works now
here's the problem when you have to
that's a wheel gun so as you're pointing
the gun toward the camera you have to
have uh the bullets have to be in the
gun it has to look that way otherwise
people can wear the bullets right so
even then what you you know they'll show
you the gun they'll show you that it's
blanks they show you the whole thing
what's confusing to me is that that
wasn't done well that's what they so it
says D.A says Baldwin was supposed to
undergo firearms training but failed to
do so adding Baldwin was then supposed
to get minimal training for 30 minutes
but was on a cell phone for most of the
time in the speaking with his family
again he's done this so long that it's
like I you know what that training is
that training is hey this is a gun this
is the trigger don't point it to
somebody it's all that stuff that he's
heard a thousand times that he's
literally like wear his seat belt so
then this is where else is liable the
district attorney goes on to say as a
producer of the movie Baldwin should
never have allowed the production
company to hire Hannah Reed as she
lacked the certifications experience for
the job apparently her dad's a big time
in this field she don't have the
experience and they just hired her okay
and I'd like to say something about that
too from what I hear what I hear from
people she was also uh there was also a
lot of pressure to hire women and people
who were not usually as represented in
those jobs see this is where it gets
diced too though the D.A lays the
numerous safety lapses on the set at
Baldwin's doorstep saying he did not
address those issues which even result
in crew members walking off this this is
true prior they're like hey this isn't
safe I heard that too they kept doing it
I heard that too again that's because
you guys hired a very inexperienced
young gal because it was checking a box
or whatever and because I can promise
you that her dad wasn't available there
were plenty of people who were guys who
knows we've been doing it for 40 years
who are available I promise yeah and
that's where the whole thing for
politics yes it's very weird to me
because also you would never point a gun
and shoot it no never but sometimes you
never have your hands on the trigger
yeah but but that again that might have
been it might have been it might have
been cocked it might have had this crap
if you ever shot like a 1911 or whatever
the [__] it is it's like my dad has a 45
you touch that trigger you touch it but
like my boys I was telling his big move
star he was like no you don't you never
pull the trigger no matter what he's
like even especially in rehearsal
because I don't rehearse with real guns
I just go like this bang bang because I
don't know what the [__] they were doing
yeah I don't either you say it's very
strange because I remember upset where
they'd even allow that he's like that's
how loosey-goosey they were on that side
that's crazy he's saying that's a
problem if Alex the producer he's in
charge of a lot of that stuff
yeah he's like no you can point blame on
whoever you want but the end of the day
it's like a head coach Point blame the
reason we lost game is the quarterback
well no you're in charge of the Court
yes the reason we lost the game is the
defense okay we're in charge of the
defense coordinator who runs the defense
and oh you have to take has uh Jocko
would say you know complete ownership
just don't you gotta own it you gotta
own it the one of the most surreal
excuse my life was was on on set a ride
along big movie with yeah and there's a
huge shootout scene huge shootout scene
I believe can you look up Sandy Hook and
then can you look up when Ride Along
came out I believe it was after the
Sandy Hook disaster yes the and the San
Diego shooting it's December 2012. yeah
see when Ride Along was I believe this
is when it happened and we had the so
it's the day
um 2014. there you go so so
um I I think it was when Sandy Hook
happened I believe that was the tragedy
and um our producer great guy
um
will Packer led a moment of silence he
said I don't know if you all heard about
this took his hat off we all sat and we
were all silent in memory of these
children because you guys probably shot
that but what a year something like that
uh so I don't know if that's I don't
know if Sandy Hook I don't know if those
those dates match today that's two years
so you might have took two years of film
maybe yeah maybe during production it
could have been I don't remember it was
a terrible tragedy and uh and it was but
it was a gun violence thing we all kind
of like went like that and he goes thank
you guys all right and that day was the
the day that there were more guns on set
when I'm not and more shooting than you
can even [__] believe like you cannot
believe it
yeah all of us
and just explosive everywhere you're
shooting blanks and everything else but
when you're in a situation like that you
got not only do you have like the
uh what is it the Master of Arms or
whatever the guy who runs you got
[__] like Soldier Seal Team guys who
are like everybody Consultants yeah when
even when I did that awful Tax Collector
movies a ton of guns there was like
seven former Navy Seals on the set and
they were each assigned a person who had
a real AK-47 they on off suit they would
take it from you that's right they take
it from yeah that's right yeah you don't
you're not holding that gun you're
you're it's taken so it's a very strange
thing yeah it's about it's just a bummer
all the way around yeah what else you
got to give some good events though yeah
all right so this is one of the biggest
things ever that's going on here in the
states it's uh this weather balloon from
China they consider it a weather balloon
but then uh Americans [__] yeah like a
surveillance type of balloon I can't
believe how long it took to shoot down
but finally they got it down yeah
there's there's a lot of theory series
on this like first of all they have
satellites why are they using a balloon
that's what Jay goes they can't begin
Intel because their satellites they take
much better pictures of that [__]
yeah but it might have been uh they're
doing some listening device but the
listening device or they're saying that
uh China could was testing to see they
can set off a nuclear bomb up in the sky
which would ruin all our communication
like shut down cell service with no
communication to anywhere inside the
world so they could be addicted here's
the thing I'm gonna [__] what they're
Collective we can't have it right like
somebody said Trump tweet maybe lives
you see Trump's tweet he's such a Savage
he goes he goes giant he goes Chinese
lucky Biden's president and I'm sure
they're chinese-made uh made in China
bombs or made in China balloons If I Was
President you'd see made in America F-16
Jets headed your way as we speak but I'm
not president
the answer was probably like well we
probably have our own balloons over
China it doesn't matter yeah it doesn't
matter but we wanted to get our [__] out
of the way first you know it's cool
Watsons take it down though it's a great
video too of that yeah it just seemed
like there's anime uh like Chris Weidman
even posted there's a bunch of jets
flying around it too I didn't see it in
South Carolina there's an HD one it's
just like Splash where I didn't see that
let me see that bring it up really yeah
and so it was a plane that shot that
yeah but apparently they shut down over
a body of water so yeah I'm sure they're
gonna collect it yeah
yeah there was a channel like how dare
you shoot it down you gotta say stuff
but it's like guys you're you're the
wind blew you
you know
in that
Direction and these look familiar uh
that one right there was all puffy now
that though yeah so we probably can't
believe this but it was off the coast of
South Carolina not on it how come we
can't play [__] on YouTube this gets
flagged we don't own it it's funny those
people are all freaking all these
balloons like Kate but dumbasses use
tick tock the biggest spyware period
where they have all your information are
you worried about this balloon I like
any of it [__] all of it tick tock that
balloon get rid of all of it I'm with
you 2K was like wake up people what are
you gonna figure it out yeah I'm with
you on that I'm [__] with you 100 on
that
it's like yeah
also the hypocrisy of like I mean just
people who are
trying to be consistent
not so easy
yeah we didn't find a great video but
either way we can't show it anyways yeah
so they shot it down
um
you follow Sports a lot and you've
watched it your whole life
the marriage of politics and sports is a
new thing isn't it like oh yeah right
like the black lives matter
and it shouldn't it should be the sports
is the one place that should be [__]
neutral happen in the NHL like they did
like some gay yeah
I'm not I'm an Orthodox Christian it's
not that's like we don't agree with it
he was also like I'm not from here I
have to go back home like if I get
caught in that Jersey it's different
there right and he got so much [__] you
get [__] up he refused to he's like it
ain't happening like oh you're anti-game
he's like censored right he's okay no if
he didn't wear the Jersey the left came
after him he's like no it's not it's a
it's against my religion yeah B I don't
live in America right so I go back home
and up they catch me right in this yeah
yeah he's like [__] [__] up [__] your
social media like I'm not worried about
that I'm not wearing this [__] exactly
it's just weird they're like oh he's
anti-game so okay if he doesn't believe
in it that makes him a bad person that's
his beliefs I don't agree with you I
would I'd be down to wear it but an
outcome from Russia I'm down the word I
just don't I'm not old I have to wear
anything correct that's my problem I'm
down to wear it you know if you said can
you wear this because you know it
supports get it rights and I'm all right
fine but don't make but you don't have
to suffer the same price as that guy
who's living in chechnya Russia yeah or
Brazil that's right but in America now
you do suffer the same you know it's
like Bill Maher is talking about this
law professor who used a theoretical
example about of a woman she's a she she
said if there's a black woman and and
somebody calls her a racial slurt and
and and does it again and he didn't say
the register but he used the first
letter in the word they they he's taken
they they kicked him off campus he's got
to take sensitivity training these
people are so out of their [__] minds
colleges are so [__] gutless culture
is already [__] unless you're
playing a sport now like can you imagine
like my kids it's just the the
perspective on college has changed Daisy
Jordan Peterson starting today hey
you're just gonna get a ton of debt yeah
unless you're special president being a
lawyer or a doctor if communication
sociology you're not going to college
for that what the [__] are you talking
about well Jordan Peterson is great uh
he's trying to get a bachelor's degree
but with ice recruiting all these
professors and he's trying to get it so
that you can get a bachelor's degree for
under four thousand dollars how amazing
would that be with real education like
an education that makes you competent I
go that's cool yeah me too what else you
gotcha
uh this just came in like a half an hour
yeah 45 minutes ago very interesting
this Anthony Pettis versus Roy Jones Jr
in boxing this is under uh game bread so
yeah it's under jorgeous promotions and
I think Jose Aldo is awesome yeah here's
the whole card right here so far you
have to pass Roy Jones Jose Aldo Jeremy
Stevens boxing Victor Bell for Souza
Paul Daly Anthony Taylor Pro Gonzalez
wow wow
it's pretty sad my favorite fight on
there is belfor's uh jockery that'd be
fun Anthony Taylor Paul Davis that's a
fun card damn Belfor is fighting that's
that's who that is Ronaldo Souza yeah
Chuck Raymond's alligator it's
interesting yes
um so Pettis Roy Jones that's
interesting
that's April 1st good for mazlo dollar
that's sweet
yeah that's a big card for but Pettis is
uh that's yeah that smaller guy yeah Roy
Jones yeah I don't know
it's interesting though that'd be that
that'll be what like they'll move around
or they're going to try to uh I don't
see Mazda having you know the same
[__] that some other people do I
think you think you're pretty serious
or Jones a slick one he's older so we'll
see it's interesting Chandler the other
fights make sense that's who those guys
should be fighting I'm into it what's
your thought about Chandler McGregor it
depends what Connor we get it's at 172
depends on the counter we get but he's
being forced to train which is good
solid fight
um so we all know Mr Beast the probably
the he probably is the biggest YouTuber
in the world in North America yeah so he
uh did a video where he basically cured
a thousand people of their blindness
from cataract he got so much hate from
certain people which is so insane that's
how bad the world sucks why because he
gave people the ability to see it's like
real hater is this like Russian Bots
like what do we do no there's like these
are stupid people like you're assuming
it's a deficiency not being able to see
how do you know they won he's like
because they signed up they said no dumb
[__] no some of the hate was because
he's using these videos for clot which
who gives a [__] if he's if it's for
cloud he's spending his money it's like
3 500 bucks per surgery
he's curious he cured a thousand people
of blindness took their cataracts away
they couldn't afford it gave them a life
they can read see their grandchildren
gave some of them Teslas ten thousand
dollars and he made money doing it uh
what the [__] he promises to give away
all his money before he dies yeah but
here's the thing look at that but here's
the thing he constantly gives people you
know whatever these opportunities the
money makes up this video the next thing
he does he does stuff like this all the
time so the next thing he does is he's
gonna pay he help more people yeah he
reinvests all his money yeah how you
could hate on him if you hate him go
[__] yourself yeah how do you hate him I
I didn't think he was a real thing
either when people like you see Mr B's
getting hate him like for curing
blindness if he hears this and he
[__] pays my alimony and I'm gonna
freak out he better not I mean I will
cry
if he gives me like
a lot of money I'm gonna lose my mind
yeah here it goes it's deeply
frustrating to have a rely on a uh
benevolent which I mean is like a
kind-hearted content King making feel
good videos rather than addressing the
root cause of these problems oh yes
who knows who have you ever helped you
dumbass
oh go back it's deeply frustrating who
cares about your frustration you dumb
[__] you know what's frustrating not be
able to see yourself content King making
feel good videos rather than face you
know what well I get wait it's happened
so hold on as I've been saying that it's
too bad that it has that that a guy like
that has to do this when we don't have a
society that cures these people I got
you yeah but also he's only two thousand
dollars take it back hold on I don't
he's saying it's frustrating for him to
do it instead of addressing the root
causes like it's not Mr BEAST's uh thing
to address the root cause he's just
trying to help you you're not saying
that he's saying that it is frustrating
that we have to rely on one guy to do
that when we could solve this as a
society because whatever it's 2 000
saying why is that doesn't think he's
not gonna pay for it
all right sorry I can see it both ways
sorry the Zapp man I'm not saying sorry
wait so he's saying he's not saying that
um Mr Beast is not addressing those
problems are you saying like the society
or Society is not adjusting yeah he's
saying that he says it's it's sad we
have to we have to rely on I agree with
that comment because they're saying why
to help somebody out why doesn't the
government yeah help people out instead
of this guy on YouTube doing it for
Content which I agree with
but again you think Mr B's going to
figure out and change the laws and
legislation to pay for I'll just do some
good [__] no he's doing yeah he's
helping people yeah
yeah I I don't when people are hating
around like that's the internet
yes it is um do you guys care about this
Kyrie Irving being traded to the Mavs
I mean clearly the guy's a problem
wherever he goes like LeBron James tweet
was great he's like and I'm the problem
are you put like oh oh people think it's
me what's his problem his problem is
he's just difficult to deal with he's
16. no I mean I mean [__] the vaccines
his Jewish stuff's way worse than all
that oh really yeah yeah but he's such a
talent he's so good at basketball they
put up with it yes oh my God he's a
freak
super freak Dallas too with him and
homeboys they're gonna be good jokic
that's right
uh Rampage Jackson posted this this is
from belto uh 290 which has just
happened on Saturday
[Applause]
I guess the guy just got super super
drunk at the fights
oh
on with Tiger and there's uh Josh he's
lucky barnetta and stand up and rip his
face where's Josh Josh right there
oh yeah Josh will [__] Joshua
and they just drag him out I love him
Josh burn that's a great guy forget him
on the podcast yeah
let's see yeah well something yeah it's
mad fate or lost last time I can see him
and this is the last one thirst trap
thirst trap Friday Brady single now like
what's up [__] junk skinny legs
those are some very skinny legs the goat
he has a rumored girlfriend or a girl
that was yeah she's a thirsting of him
yeah don't judge a book by its cover you
look
he looks the best quarterback of all
time yes
girl oh well Tom Brady's girlfriend is
pretty that's his girlfriend yeah okay
rumored girlfriend
yeah yeah that's what happens when
you're Tom you're the greatest of all
time you're gonna get some tits thrown
your way
yeah
all right
um dates Brian
my dates are you are you still are you
taking some time off me I'm going to be
in Canada comic strip February 23 24 25
Nashville Tennessee Zanies March 2 3 and
4. New York New York Stony Hall March
11th those tickets are going fast Sony
Hall New York March 11th West Nyack New
Jersey New York uh Levity Live March 16
17 18. uh and also this weekend with
Talon Eddie Bravo Joe Rogan doing the
fight campaign he goes live at 9 00 p.m
central time that's on Rogan's YouTube
and then the full episode will be
uploaded to his Spotify Channel tour
dates next week uh February 16th through
18th Naples Florida coming off the hook
and then Bakersfield's one night only
almost sold out one night only it's a
Thursday night February 23rd then Brea
California's one night only two March
3rd two shows on that Friday because
Saturday March 4th I have a fight
campaign uh we have jelly roll we have
Rampage and a very special guest that's
March 4th on thick Boy network for the
Jon Jones uh UFC 285 the Oklahoma City
March 9th through the 11th Tacoma but uh
Naples Europe next week Friday Thursday
Friday Saturday Naples Florida then
Bakersfield One Night February 23rd get
your tickets at fatkz.com or
thickboy.com that's it kids
that's the episode love ya I think
Wednesday we got a special guest too
enjoy your week that's it we're out